est-il arrivé au puc à l'aise breizh ce
chalutier français qui a coulé
mystérieusement au large de l'angleterre
en janvier 2004 la justice britannique
rend son jugement ce vendredi mais voilà
presque dix huit ans que les familles
des victimes se bat pour connaître la
vérité mon frère est au fond de nous
vous voulez vous faire votre deuil c'est
pas possible pas possible 15 janvier
2004 le bugaled breizh cool en quelques
secondes seulement bilan deux morts
trois disparus collision avec un autre
bateau accrochage avec un sous-marin l'
enquête piétine et les familles des
victimes perdent patience c'est
inadmissible on tue cinq hommes mais
foster
et ces gens leur travail et n'ont rien
demandé à personne
l'accrochage avec un sous-marin c'est
l'hypothèse défendue par les familles
des victimes
et d'augmenter le jour du drame l'otan
participé à un exercice militaire dans
la zone du naufrage en 2005 michèle
alliot marie alors ministre de la
défense décide de déclassifier les
activités maritimes dans la région
prudence chez les familles des victimes
on espère beaucoup plus maintenant de
l'état anglais je pense qu'elle ait qui
lève aussi le secret défense pour pour
savoir exactement quel navire est ici
c'est une impasse la levée du secret
défense ne permet pas de déterminer les
causes de l'accident l' enquête piétine
encore pendant des années et en 2014
stupeur la justice française clôture les
investigations avec un non-lieu colère
du frère d'une des victimes ce bateau en
dix ans et entendre ça non
non l'état français
non la justice nom de van hamme tôt
bureau nom de monsieur le drian c'est
juste pas possible les familles des
victimes font appel mais le 21 juin 2016
nouveau coup de massue la cour de
cassation valide le non lieu le combat
continue on sait qu'il ya des forces en
france qui font que dans ce domaine
particulier on dit jamais la vérité
c'est comme ça et il faut faire avec
l'enquêté close en france mais en
angleterre une procédure judiciaire
s'est ouverte en 2010 cet accident de
pêche collision avec un sous-marin
verdict ce vendredi à londres après près
de trois semaines d'audience
[Musique]